Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Herkese günaydın.
Öncelikle size
iki tane soru sormak istiyorum:
Mars'a giderken yanınıza alacağınız
üç şey ne olurdu?
Ya da Mars's ayak basan kişi
ilk siz olsaydınız,
kuracağınız ilk cümle ne olurdu?
Aranızda beni tanıyanlar,
uzay keşfine
ne kadar da tutkun olduğumu bilirler;
ama bu tutku sadece soyut değil,
aynı zamanda somut katkılar yapmak
benim hayat girdabımı oluşturuyor.
Üniversite hayatı vizyonumuzu,
karakterimizi, öz güvenimizi
ve cesaretimizi belirlediğimiz
bir zaman dilimidir.
Uzay mühendisliğini ilk tercih ettiğimde,
benim için anlamı sadece sosyal bir konum
ya da iyi bir maaş olmadı.
Çünkü geleceğin bilinmezlik girdabına
gözüm kapalı atlarken,
bedelinin öncelikle özveri
ve çalışmak olduğunu biliyordum.
O yüzden üniversitede kendime
uzay çalışmalarında geleceğe yön verecek
hedefler koydum ve bazılarına ulaştım.
Bu süreçte
sizinle paylaşabileceğim birçok anı var.
Ama ilk olarak, küresel vizyonun
öneminden bahsetmek istiyorum.
Uluslararası Uzay Federasyonu tarafından,
Genç Profesyoneller Delegesi olarak
Türkiye'den seçilen kişi olmuştum.
2002'den beri NASA başkanı,
Boeing, Airbus gibi şirketlerin CEO'ları
ya da Buzz Aldrin, Chris Hadfield gibi
ünlü astronotlarla tanıştık
ve toplantılar yaptık.
Bu süreçlerde beni en çok etkileyen ise
samimiyet ve doğallık oldu.
NASA başkanı Charlie Bolden,
dersiniz ki böyle korumalarla gezer falan,
hiç de öyle değil!
Kanada'daki balayı hikâyesini anlattı
ve daha sıcak bir ülkeye gitmediği için
duyduğu pişmanlığı dile getirmişti.
Yine Lockheed Martin,
Amerika'nın önde gelen savunma sanayii
şirketlerinden birisinin CEO'su;
Marillyn Hewson,
Forbes dergisi tarafından dünyanın en
güçlü 50 kadını içerisinde gösteriliyor,
ama benimle o kadar samimi sohbet etti ki,
çok etkilenmiştim.
Yaşınıza ve mevkinize bakmadan,
insanlar sizin sadece gözünüzün
içine bakarak sohbet ediyor
ve sizi dinliyorlar
ve değer veriyorlar.
Türkiye ESA'ya,
Avrupa Uzay Ajansı'na üye değildir.
Yine ESA için düzenlenen bir toplantıda,
tek Türk bendim.
Diğer ülkelerden katılımcı arkadaşlar ile
hazırladığımız rapor,
bakanlık seviyesinde bir toplatıda sunuldu
ve bu da uluslararası
iş birliğinin önemini gösteriyor.
Açıkçası uzay sektöründe,
dünyada olup biteni ilk elden öğrenmek
çok faydalı oldu benim için
ve Türkiye için de
bir katkı olduğunu düşünüyorum,
ama bu süreçlerde
düşündürücü birkaç anım da mevcut.
[-Bu gezegende 1 saat Dünya'da 7 yıla eşit.
+Süper! Doktoramı bu gezegende bitireceğim.]
Geçen sene Los Angeles'ta
bir konferansta, sunum yaptım
ve sonrasında,
bu esprili fotoğrafı göstermiştim.
Çıkışında Türkiye'de çalışan
bir mühendis yanıma geldi.
"Bir dakika, bir şey söyleyebilir miyim?
Her şey çok iyi de" dedi,
"şu fotoğrafta neden astronotlar
Amerikan bayrağı taşıyor?" dedi.
Şimdi, biraz donup kaldım,
çünkü bu bir espri ve film karesi
ve ben de 30 dakikalık beni terleten
teknik bir sunum yapmışım
Sonra pek bir şey diyemedim,
biraz da hata verdim böyle.
Sonra yanımdan ayrıldı,
o da bir şey diyemedi.
Benzer bir konu Kanada'da meydana geldi.
Yine böyle aktif sunumlar sonrası,
heyecanımı Türkiye'den üst düzey
bir kurumdan katılımcıyla paylaşıyorum.
Beni böyle dinlerken işte onay veriyor,
"Evet, tamam" deyip
kafasını sallıyordu ama,
konuşmam bitti, yorum beklerken
hâlâ bu transa geçmiş devam ediyor.
Ben böyle yine şaşırdım.
Tabii böyle farkındalığı düşük insanlar da
katılabiliyor etkinliklere.
NASA'dan birkaç üst düzey yöneticiyle
artık arkadaş gibiyim
ve bana Türkiye'den gelen heyetlerin
"Bize astronot verin, yoksa anlaşmayız"
şeklinde böyle yaklaşımlarını bile
paylaştılar.
Böylece benim anılarım resmileşmiş oldu.
Bu hikâyelerden sonra,
Türkiye'nin uluslararası anlamda
ne kadar zorlu bir girdap içinde olduğunu
görebiliyorsunuz.
Ben de bunu değiştirmek için
çok çaba sarf ediyorum
ve hayat girdabım olan
uzay ve Mars keşfimi de
sizinle paylaşmak istiyorum.
Biz sadece dış uzayı değil,
içimizi de keşfediyoruz.
Dünya'yı daha iyi anlamak,
doğal afetlere çözüm üretebilmek için.
Olaylara yukarıdan bakmanın
her zaman daha objektif olduğunu söyleriz.
İşte bu da,
Uluslararası Uzay İstasyonu tarafından
çekilmiş en güncel İstanbul fotoğrafı
ve bize "Hey, bak! Aşağıda bir şeyler
oluyor, bir şeyler yapmanız lazım!" diyor.
Betonlaşmanın
nasıl yayıldığını görebilirsiniz.
Bu gözlemlerin hepsi,
şu an 400 kilometre yukarımızdaki
bir futbol sahası büyüklüğündeki
Uluslararası Uzay İstasyonundan yapılıyor
ve fotoğraflar da özel olarak
Cupola kapsülünden çekiliyor.
Aynı zamanda astronotların selfie çekip
ya da gitar çaldığı bir kapsüldür.
Bu çok beğendiğim bir gif.
Astronotların günlük hayatı
bize çok benziyor;
9-5 çalışıyorlar,
mikro yerçekim etkilerini
anlamak için deneyler yapıyorlar,
aynı zamanda uzay istasyonu Dünya'nın
çevresini 90 dakikada tamamlıyor.
Yani biz bir gün doğumu,
bir gün batımı yaşarken
onlar sekiz kere gün doğumu
ve sekiz kere gün batımı görüyorlar.
Şu an yer çekimi etkisiyle
sıvı akışı normal,
ancak uzayda sıvı akışı,
yukarı başımıza doğrudur
ve sinüzlerimize,
gözlerimize bu sıvı baskı yapar.
O yüzden,
astronotlar görme problemi yaşarlar.
Aynı zamanda
omurgamıza binen yükler de azalacağı için,
astronotlar 4-5 cm uzuyorlar
uzay istasyonunda.
Bunun yanında, kemikler ve kasların
Dünya'ya oranla
güçlü olmasına gerek yoktur.
O yüzden, kemiklerdeki kalsiyum
kana karışır, kan hacmi yükselir
ve astronotlar bir ayda, kemik
yoğunluğunun %2'sini falan kaybederler.
Ki bu biz Dünya'da
bir yılda kaybettiğimiz orana eşit.
Yapılan bazı deneylerden örnek:
İlk kez geçen sene
üç boyutlu yazıcıyla parça ürettiler
ve ilk kez marul yetiştirip
afiyetle yediler uzay istasyonunda
ve en popüler deneylerden biri de yanma.
Orada alev çok daha farklıdır,
yavaş temiz
ve tehlikesiz bir yanma süreci gerçekleşir
ve araba şirketleri
enjeksiyon sistemlerinde
bunu kullanmaya çalışıyorlar.
İşte bu bahsettiğim veriler,
bütün deneyler,
bizi tek bir hedefe hazırlıyor:
Dünya bağımsız yaşam teknolojilerini
üretmek.
Şu an Uzay İstasyonu ile
bağımlı bir şekildeyiz,
gerçek zamanlı iletişim kurabiliyoruz,
acil durumlarda 3-4 saatte ulaşabiliriz
ve astronotları gönderebiliyoruz.
Peki, Dünya Bağımsız Sistem
oluşturmak için neler yapmamız lazım?
İki tane parantez açacağım:
Birincisi ise,
Dünya'da ve mikro yer çekimi ortamındaki
sağlık verilerine sahibiz,
ama Ay ya da Mars'ta durum nedir
bilmiyoruz.
İkincisi ise,
Ay keşfi 1970'lerde yapıldı.
12 astronot Ay'a gitti
ve 1972'den bu yana hiçbir astronot
derin uzayı seyahat etmedi.
2018'de NASA, SLS roketi
ve Orion kapsülünü fırlatacak,
bu da 2030'larda bizi
Mars'a göndermeye çalışacak.
Peki Mars için durum nedir?
Plazalarda çalışan ve her gün alışveriş
merkezine yemeğe gitmekten sıkılmış
bir arkadaşımız Mars'a gitmek istiyor.
Peki ne zaman geri gelir?
2-3 seneye geri gelmiş olur,
tabii doğru zamanda çıkarsa.
Doğru zaman, doğru tarih ne demek?
Yörüngesel olarak Dünya ve Mars'ın
birbirine en yakın olduğu tarihte
çıkmamız lazım.
Mesela 22 Mayıs 2016'da çıkmış olsaydık,
ortalama 7 ayda Mars'ta olacaktık.
Bu yakınlığı tekrar beklemek için,
bir 7 ay da bekleme süresi
ve dönüş de 7 ay,
ortalama 21-24 aya ihtiyacımız vardı.
Peki, Mars'a gittiniz.
Orada 6 ay bekiyorsunuz
ve aileniz, arkadaşlarınız,
sevgilinizle haberleşeceksiniz.
Eğer Whatsapp'tan
yazılı mesaj yollarsanız,
6 dakika gecikmeli olarak haberleşirsiniz.
Diyelim sesli mesaj yolladınız
ya da selfie çektiniz, gönderdiniz.
Bu süre 20 dakikaya kadar uzar
ve sevgilinizden trip yeme ihtimalini
arttırmış olursunuz.
Şu an Curiosity yüzey aracı,
NASA'yla 13 dakikada haberleşiyor.
Bağımsız bir seviyeye gelmek için
ve Mars'ta öyle bir sistem kurmak için,
4 unsur önemli:
[Sürdürülebilirlik,
Genetik Varyasyon, Adaptasyon]
Acaba sürdürülebilir enerji
elde edebilecek miyiz?
Ya da gıdalarımızı
nasıl temin edebileceğiz?
Acaba radyasyona genetik olarak
nasıl tepki verebileceğiz?
Ya da psikolojik olarak
adapte olabilecek miyiz?
Ama bence en önemlisi de maliyet.
Trump'ın gelecek uzay görevlerindeki
yaklaşımını bilemiyorum,
ama şu an ortalama bir yüzey robotu
üretip gönderelim derseniz 2 milyar dolar.
SpaceX, TESLA Motors
ve PayPal'ın CEO'su Elon Musk,
şu an bir insanı Mars'a göndermenin
10 milyar dolara
mâl olabileceğini söylüyor.
Kafanızda daha net canlanması için
bir bütçe kıyaslaması yaptım.
Ay keşfi 150 milyar dolara mâl oldu,
NASA'nın şu anki bütçesi
19 milyar dolar civarında.
3. köprü 3 milyar dolar.
Ben de, Ay görevi hakkında
bir araştırma yapmıştım
ve hesaplamalarıma göre
200 kilogramlık bir uyduyu
100 milyon dolara
mâl edip gönderebilirsiniz.
Yani bir köprü parasına
30 tane uydu gönderip
Ay'a koloni kurma ihtimaliniz var.
Dünya ve Mars
bazı yönlerden birbirine çok benziyor.
Mesela Dünya'daki okyanusları,
suları bir kenara bırakalım;
kara parçası alanları
birbirlerine eşittir,
bir gün süresi de birbirlerine eşittir.
Ancak Mars karbondioksitle doludur,
%96'sı karbondioksittir.
Aynı zamanda, geceleri sıcaklık -100°C
ve biz yaşam olması için
bunu yükseltmemiz lazım.
Bizi asıl ilgilendiren insan nüfusu.
Marslı filmini bir kenara bırakırsanız,
Mars'ta popülasyon yok.
Dünya'nın aksine,
Mars'ta manyetik alan da yoktur.
O yüzden, radyasyondan korunamaz
ve bu çok ciddi bir tehlike.
Mars'taki atmosfer yoğunluğu,
Dünya'da deniz seviyesindeki
yoğunluğun %1'ine eşit.
Yani 100 kat daha ince atmosfere sahiptir.
Su olsaydı Mars yüzeyinde,
hemen buharlaşırdı.
Atmosfer yoğunluğu neden önemlidir?
Diyelim, ben Dünya'da
serbest atlayış yapacağım uçaktan.
Atladım ve beni yavaşlatacak
sürüklenme kuvveti nedeniyle 0.15 Mach,
yani 53 M/S hızla yere iniş yaparım.
Diyelim Mars'tan atlıyorum.
Mars'ın 100 kat
daha ince atmosferi olduğu için,
sizi yavaşlatacak kuvvet de
100 kat daha azdır
ve yavaşlayamazsınız.
Bu yüzden ben yere
1.5 Mach ile yere çarparım,
bir ses hızına 1 Mach diyoruz,
yani ses hızını aşıp yere çarparım.
Ben yok olduktan sonra bile
sesimi hâlâ duyarsınız.
Gerçek görevlerde ise durum şu şekilde:
Aracınız Mars'a girdikten sonra,
yavaşlaması için 7 dakikanız var.
O yüzden NASA buna
"7 Dakikalık Terör" diyor.
Eğer yavaşlayamazsanız, 10 yıllık
emeğiniz ve 2 milyar dolarınız çöpe gider.
Bu, Phoenix yüzey aracı tarafından
çekilmiş gerçek bir görüntü.
Bu sarı bölgedeki buzun 4 gün içinde
nasıl buharlaştığını görebiliyorsunuz,
bu da atmosfer yoğunluğunun
çok ince olmasından kaynaklanıyor.
Atmosferik basınç Dünya'da
deniz seviyesinde 101 kPa.
Mars'ta ortalama ise 0.6 kPa,
çok düşük bir değer.
Bu değeri yükseltmemiz lazım
eğer Mars'ı Dünyalaştırmak istiyorsak.
İlk olarak Armstrong sınırını
0.6 kPa değerini aşmamız lazım
ve bunun için bazı kimyasal yöntemler var.
Mars'ı ısıtıp,
yüzeyindeki buzları eritip,
içindeki karbondioksiti
atmosfere yayabiliriz.
Bu şekilde atmosfer kalınlaşabilir.
Ya da dışarıdan metan, hidrokarbon
takviyesi yaparız Mars'a bir şekilde
ve Dünya'daki gibi
"green house" etkisi yaratabiliriz.
Zaten %96'sı karbondioksit olan
bir atmosferde onları yakalayıp
Sabatier yöntemiyle su oluşturabiliriz.
Yine benzer bir şekilde,
karbondioksiti yakalayıp metan ve oksijen
üreterek roket yakıtı elde edebiliriz
ve Mars yüzeyinde bize
destek birimi olarak yardımcı olur.
Bunlar için tabii ki gereken enerji
Güneş panellerinden sağlanabilir.
Bunlar kimyasal olarak çok doğru, ama
pratikte gidecek çok yolumuz var.
Neden?
Çünkü bu figür
NASA tarafından oluşturulmuş
ve Mars'a düzenlenen görevleri gösteriyor.
Şu ana kadar 40'ın üzerinde görev yapıldı
ve başarı oranı sadece %38.
Çok düşük bir başarı.
Bunu yükseltmemiz lazım.
Benim de konferanslarda sunduğum
bazı fikirler ve hesaplamalar mevcut.
Size sonuçlarından kısaca
figürlerle göstermek istiyorum.
Astronotlar bir bölgede çalışırken,
diğer bölgede yüzeyde robotların,
atmosferde ise insansız hava aracı
ya da glider dediğimiz
süzülen araçların
olduğu bir sistem yaratabiliriz.
Glider dememin sebebi,
bizim bir parantez açayım,
akışkanlar mekaniğinde
Reynolds sayısı diye bir değerimiz var.
Bu Mars'ta çok düşük.
O yüzden bu şekilde süzülen araçlar
Mars atmosferinde ancak işleyebilir.
Bunun dışında, elimizde bitki
ve bakteri fonksiyonları konusunda
hiçbir verimiz yok.
O yüzden insanlı görevlerden önce
mutlaka bitki yetiştirip
bakteri kültürü oluşturmamız lazım.
Tabii bunlar için
bir plana ihtiyacımız var.
Mevcut bütün uydu
ve robotlardan alacağımız verileri
bir sanal gerçeklik ortamına
aktarabiliriz.
Bu ortamda astronotlar,
Mars'a gitmeden önce bitki yetiştirip
radyasyon testleri yapabilirler
ve sonuçlarını görebilirler ve bizim
başarısızlık oranımızı düşürür bu.
2018 kritik bir yıl.
Daha önce de dediğim gibi,
Orion kapsülü ve SLS roketi
yeni nesil teknolojiler fırlatılacak
ve bunların uçuş seslerinin
yapılması gerekiyor.
2020'lerde,
yeni yüzey robotları fırlatılacak
ve bunlardan aldığımız veriler ile
bizim simülasyonlarımızı
güncelleyebiliriz.
Aynı zamanda,
bütçe dengesi de çok önemlidir.
Niye?
Çünkü 2020'lerde,
uzay istasyonu göstermiştim,
onun bilimsel operasyonu
2024'te durdurulması planlanıyor
ve daha çok turistik amaçlarla ya da
ticari amaçlarla kullanılması planlanıyor.
Bundan elde edilecek kârlar olabilir,
bütün işte ajanslar,
şirketler ve organizasyonlar
yeni bir bütçe dengesi yaratması
gerekiyor.
Bahsettiğim destek birimlerini Mars'a
fırlatıp, operasyon oluşturarak
ve bunların da
hazır olması lazım tabii ki,
insanları göndermeden önce
emin olmalıyız çalışıp çalışmadığından.
Bunları yaptıktan sonra da,
30'lardan sonra, 35'lerden sonra,
ilk insanlı görevi yapabiliriz.
Mars yolculuğu sırasında
yeni teknolojiler üretip
bilimsel tecrübemizi arttıracağız
ve en önemlisi
Mars keşfi gelecek nesiller için
hayal gücünü gerçekliğe
dönüştürme mücadelesi olacaktır.
Hayal gücünü ve gerçeklik kurgusunun
en önemli örneği,
Jules Verne'ün
Ay'a Seyahat isimli eseridir.
Onun gibi dünyaya yön vermiş
bilim insanları
ya da girişimcilerin ortak noktası,
kendilerini ilerleyen geleceğin
bilinmezlik girdabına
cesaretle bırakmalarıdır.
Geleceğimizi daha iyi kurmak için,
ortak girdabımız olan hayal gücü
macerasında yapmamız gereken
önceki ve sonraki nesiller arasında
bir köprü oluşturmaktır.
Çalışma tutkumuzu ve bilincimizi
gençler ile her daim paylaşmalıyız.
Karanlığın içinde parıldayan
bir mücevherde,
çok ilginç bir zaman diliminde yaşıyoruz.
Teşekkürler!
(Alkış)